ausgangssperren halte ich für ein ganz
falsches mittel
wir haben das auch nie nordrhein
westfalen gemacht und insofern sollten
wir die anderen möglichkeiten nutzen die
ich eben beschrieben habe das impfen das
testen und das digitale das ist die
antwort die wir jetzt brauchen
und in der tat ja da ist vertrauen
verloren gegangen
ich finde es übrigens richtig wenn man
in einem solchen moment dann auch die
notbremse zieht und das offen zugibt und
sagt das war ein fehler und vertrauen
gewinnt man zurück wenn man jetzt in den
nächsten entscheidungen ist besser macht
die kollege hessens ministerpräsident
volker bouffier hat heute aber in der
sitzung gesagt wir sind jetzt die deppen
hat er recht ja schön war das jedenfalls
nicht und überzeugend war es auch nicht
was wir da abgeliefert haben
die art der verhandlungsführung muss
sich verändern wir müssen auch mal
untereinander offen ideen abwägen können
ohne dass es gleich bei ihnen herr
ronzheimer der sehr gut informiert
journalist sind landet und man muss auch
sich mal korrigieren können also wir
brauchen schon in dieser
entscheidungsfindung zwischen bund und
ländern ein neues vertrauen
untereinander
das wäre gut und der weg der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wo sich 16
länder verständigen über parteigrenzen
hinweg der bleibt richtig und der hat
uns im letzten jahr auch gut durch die
pandemie gebracht mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bet schaut euch
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren